l'assaut des forces de l'ordre les
hommes du raid et imminent les policiers
d'élite du raid donnent l'assaut contre
un appartement situé en plein coeur de
saint d'élise 2015 la france subit les
pires attaques terroristes de son
histoire en première ligne les hommes du
raid une force spéciale d'intervention
de la police nationale créée le 23
octobre 1985
dès sa première année le raid doit gérer
une situation extrême au palais de
justice de nantes
un braqueur qui passer en jugement prend
l'assistance en otage recherche
assistance intervention dissuasion le
raid en place autour du palais de
justice de nantes est la dernière née
des cellules d'intervention spécialisée
dans les prises d'otages ou les affaires
de terrorisme
au bout de deux jours de négociations
les otages sont libérés sains et saufs
le malfaiteur et ses complices sont
arrêtés la méthode de robert broussard
le fondateur du raid c'est la patience
faut savoir parlementer négociée n'ait
pas brusquer les événements de savoir
dédramatiser obtenir progressivement le
que l'on relâché et et des hôtels
les arrestations du noyau dur d'action
directe en 1987 divan colonna en 2003 ou
encore de jean pierre treiber en 2009
autant d'opérations réussies sans verser
le sang ce qui ne fut pas le cas en 1993
human bomb le preneur d'otage d'une
classe maternelle de neuilly est abattu
dans l'assaut du raid après deux jours
charles pasqua le ministre de
l'intérieur peut être soulagé et le
forcené au cours des années 2000 devant
la nouvelle menace du terrorisme
islamiste
le raid voit ses effectifs renforcés
et en 2008 il collabore pour la première
fois avec le gign
son équivalent dans la gendarmerie cette
année les deux unités ont commencé à
travailler ensemble comme ici au mois
d'avril sur le problème du terrorisme de
masse en france et à l'étranger
un terrorisme de masquer leur aide va
combattre tout au long des années 2010
avec l'assaut contre l'appartement de
mohamed merah à toulouse en 2012
les assauts contre les prises d'otages
de l'hyper cacher et du bataclan 2015 il
n'ya encore la traque de chérif cheikh
at à strasbourg en 2018
désormais larmes principal c'est la
rapidité d'intervention
il ya plusieurs années ont gagné du
temps pour sauver les otages les
victimes et cetera
aujourd'hui il ne faut surtout pas
perdre de temps et donc intervenir très
rapidement pour sauver des otages depuis
sa création trois policiers du raid sont
morts dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions
[Musique]